[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 27 juin bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78 reflet de
l'actualité locale et régionale voici
les titres de cette édition
l'épisode caniculaire encore présents
pour la fin de semaine les journées les
plus chaudes sont attendus pour demain
et samedi en conséquent six écoles ont
été fermées dans les yvelines et la
circulation différenciée est reconduite
demain le véhicule électrique qui n'est
pas concerné bien sûr par les
restrictions en ile-de-france la
technologie continue même d'évoluer le
technocentre renault à guyancourt a
développé une station de recharge
innovantes reportage et puis c'est
demain soir au parc des princes la
france affronte les etats-unis en quarts
de finale du mondial féminin de football
pour préparer le match les américaines
triple championne du monde s'entraîne ce
soir à croissy-sur-seine nous serons sur
place et dans un instant on parle du
mouvement de grève qui se déroule
actuellement à cheslea sapeurs pompiers
professionnels elle les yvelines donc
toujours sous le coup de la vigilance
orange à la canicule il a encore fait
très chaud aujourd'hui vous le voyez sur
ces images d'océane bazire et d'audrey
chaillou est les terrasses de café les
parcs fui cet après midi en raison des
températures canicules et pics de
pollution la circulation différencier
sera d'ailleurs reconduite demain en
ile-de-france interdiction de rouler
pour les véhicules avec une vignette
trois et quatre et cinq vignettes
critères à l'intérieur du périmètre de
l'a86 à la chaleur qui devrait se faire
encore plus pesante demain et samedi
les prévisions météo à saint quentin en
yvelines annonce 19 degrés dès le matin
l'après midi le mercure devrait monter
au moins à 33 degrés à ces samedi que
les thermomètres grimperont le plus aux
36 degrés avant de perdre une dizaine de
degrés dimanche mais ce sera encore
chaud juste en dessous des 30 degrés à
penser en cette période à bien vous
hydrater à vous alimenter convenablement
et à vous mettre également dans des
endroits frais et je vous en parlais
hier brièvement trois communes des
yvelines ont pris des arrêtés municipaux
afin de fermer leur école aujourd'hui et
demain en raison de la chaleur six
établissements sont concernés en tout à
gargenville les élémentaire jeanne
couvrit et molière reste porte
laws au contraire de l'école corneille
construite dans les années 30 mais dont
les murs épais frenda chaleur est le
perray en yvelines a pris des
dispositions pour trois de ces
établissements scolaires enfin arrêté
également à saint martin la garenne à
d'autres communes comme voisins le
bretonneux n'ont pas pris la décision de
fermer leur école elle mais incite les
parents à garder tout de même leurs
enfants à la maison dans la mesure du
possible
enfin sur cette canicule un des
dispositions sont également prises au
sein des prisons un plan national mis en
place par l'administration pénitentiaire
décliner notamment à la maison d'arrêt
de bois d'arcy et c'est avec 930 détenus
la distribution d'eau à volonté avec ses
quotidiens aux douches la direction
facilite également l'achat de
ventilateurs à prix réduit autre mesure
l'autorisation de porter un couvre chef
dans la cour de promenade une pratique à
l'accoutumée interdite
et en cette période les autorités les
services de secours sont forcément sur
le qui vive avec moi en plateau
l'adjudant chef pierre ruiz dupont
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le président
du syndicat autonome des
sapeurs-pompiers à des yvelines les
pompiers professionnels qui ont entamé
un mouvement de grève c'était mercredi
et ce mouvement de tête se déroule
jusqu'au 31 août on en parle dans un
instant et en ce moment on imagine les
pompiers qui sont mobilisés sur sur
cette épisode de canicule
effectivement grégory il ya un mouvement
qui est préparé puisqu'on a été on a mis
les choses en place deux actions la
première action par le ministère de la
santé par les consignes que vous venez
de données qui permettent aux gens de
prendre soin d'eux et ensuite nous on a
mis en place des protocoles
d'intervention qui nous permettent de
récupérer quelqu'un en hyperthermie et
le refroidir au plus vite
et du coup davantage d'interventions
dans ses derniers instants
la prévention sanctionne puisqu'on n'est
pas surchargé par ses interventions on
peut cibler à deux trois interventions
par jour mais à savoir si elles sont dix
à la chaleur c'est encore un peu trop
tôt alors à l'appel de sept syndicats
dont le vôtre les sapeurs-pompiers ont
entamé un mouvement de grève qui est
prévue jusqu'au 31 août
un manque de moyens solides si
sollicitations également en augmentation
pour des missions qui ne sont pas les
vôtres à la base c'est ça que vous
dénoncez notamment il ya plusieurs
motifs de contestations absolument
trigoria différents motifs important à
savoir c'est par une fois c'est
particulier c'est l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales qui ont appelé
à la grève
et dans cet ensemble de reconnaissance
syndicale de toutes catégories
confondues d'accord c'est un racing en
première c'est une première et de plus
la fédération nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers de france a alerté par
votre prêt si hier en disant qu'il
fallait à se faire attention au climat
social des sapeurs pompiers
professionnels pourquoi parce qu'il ya
différents facteurs le premier c'est un
déni de dialogue social on peut prendre
un exemple très simple notre président
de la conférence nationale des services
d'incendié et de secours
monsieur en fout nous dit que les
particules de fumée ne sont pas
dangereuses alors que dans chaque
département des protocoles sont mis en
place pour décontaminer les autres méga
quand ils reviennent d'opération ensuite
il nous dit qu'on travaille trop alors
que côté professionnel travail 2256
there and m vous vouliez le social il ya
un vrai problème de fond je reviens
rapidement sur ces chiffres 1607 heures
par un fonctionnaire de 1250 6 heures
pour nous et dans ses 2250 6 heures il
ya 650 heures c'est un peu lourd prendre
ces chiffres il ya 650 heures sur
lesquels on n'est pas rémunéré c'est
vraiment il faut l'entendre c'est un peu
le l'engagement des sapeurs-pompiers qui
est là avec davantage d'interventions je
le disais tout à l'heure qui sont
organisés pour des secours aux victimes
et sans forcément de danger
pour la santé pour pour la vie c'est ça
c'est davantage d'interventions il y à
des pics l'intervention certainement dû
à un problème d'éducation de la société
qui aujourd'hui prend les pompiers pour
une énorme caisse à outils donc il nous
appelle nous intervenons puisque nous
intervenons c'est le principe de notre
métier mais c'est vrai qu'il ya une
vraie éducation aux quelques chiffres
sur 85% en ambulance si on a une
quarantaine qui sont pas des détresses
vitales
ces détresses vitales ce sont nos
missions si nous sommes pas dans ces
détresses vitales là il va y avoir des
morts un exemple tout simple on peut
prendre on est un appel pour un robinet
à fermer je vais fermer un robinet et à
ce moment là votre enfant le vôtre celui
de votre ami se fait percuter par une
voiture et là il est possible que les
sapeurs-pompiers mettre un peu plus de
temps à venir puisqu'ils ne sont pas
suffisamment nombreux
suffisament sur des interventions qui
sont pour le coup importante très
intense un peu pas obligatoirement des
opérations importantes en commun bien en
volume mais des détresses vitales
on fait de moins en moins détresse
vitale quelques chiffres est aujourd'hui
aux urgences sur 100 personnes y en a
moins de 10% à savoir 10 personnes qui
sont en détresse vitale donc par contre
il y a un vrai problème
on parlait tout à l'heure du déni
dialogue social le recrutement on fait
partie le recrutement il faut vraiment
qu'on récupère des sapeurs-pompiers
festif aujourd'hui 40 milles environ
sapeurs pompiers professionnels
absolument absolument 48
sapeurs-pompiers professionnels qui sont
pas suffisamment au nombre est mal
répartie certainement également quelques
combats de la liberté syndicale puisque
aujourd'hui nous avons un comité
d'hygiène et sécurité et un comité
technique les projets ces deux
additionnés les deux ça va nous manquer
on va avoir un problème de dialogue
il ya également d'autres poids si vous
permettez très bien je vous remercie
la rentrée le retrait de ce nouveau
projet au niveau de la fonction publique
territoriale la fonction publique tout
simplement qui va déséquilibrer notre
fonctionnement le fonctionnement de
l'état c'est quand même un peu dommage
on prend si on prend en exemple tout ce
qui s'est passé en europe la grèce par
exemple au moment où elle s'est
effondrée les seules choses qu'on peut
permettre qu'elles tiennent debout c'est
l'état donc aujourd'hui on entre à 2011
et les actifs concrètement aujourd'hui
concrètement du dialogue social
le retrait de 7 ce projet la libye de
maintenir cette commission d'hygiène de
sécurité et le comité technique
on demande une revalidation une part non
excusez mon revalorisation salariale
s'cusez moi j'ai un peu shu chez vous
sur la prime de feu c'est une prime qui
est dédié aux métiers dangereux mais
nous sommes pas un métier dangereux
puisque un métier dangereux à une prime
de 28% en 1990 nous avions obtenu 19%
aujourd'hui le pourcentage est en
vacances on y distingue pas pourquoi
parce que nos autorités de tutelle ont
défini qu'on n'était pas un métier
dangereux
et oui les sapeurs-pompiers sont pas un
métier dangereux un dernier mot très
rapidement ce qu'on arrive à la fin de
cet entretien c'est un mouvement de
grève un peu spécial parce que les
pompiers restent mobilisés vous assurez
une mission de service public comment du
coup ça va se voir cette grève comment
vous allez l'amener effet grattements le
fonctionnaire n'a pas de droit de grève
et le sapeur pompier quelqu'un de
discipliné et très investi dans ce qu'il
fait comme à peu près tous les
fonctionnaires
est ce qu'ils vont faire on se déclarent
grévistes on est réquisitionnée et or
donc on réalise la mission donc il n'y
aura pas de difficulté à réaliser les
missions des sapeurs pompiers il y aura
des effectifs en classe
très bien merci beaucoup pierre ruiz
dupont adjudant-chef pire vis du point
je rappelle que ce mouvement de grève il
a jusqu'au 31 août
je rappelle aussi vous êtes le président
du syndicat autonome des sapeurs
pompiers des yvelines passé une
excellente innovation l'écosystème du
véhicule électrique évolué avec des
technologies développées notamment au
site renault de guyancourt c'est le cas
d'une station pour recharger sa voiture
installé sur le site de recherche et
développement reportage de nicolas
d'andré et d'audrey chaillou c'est un
dispositif d'intelligence énergétique
pour recharger un véhicule électrique
une station composé de 70 m² de panneaux
solaires et de deux batteries de
voitures destinées au stockage un
système classique de rechargement
alimenté par une production d'énergie
innovante alors à l'intérieur ce
conteneur réalisé par bouygues énergie
et services vous avez retrouvé en fait
deux batteries de kangoo usagers qui si
on était vraiment été on voit ils sont
dans leurs étagères et utilisation
automobile elle vous trouvez de
l'électronique de puissance pour une
fête exploiter ses batteries et
convertir le
l'énergie de manière à pouvoir recharger
le véhicule par ce biais la voiture est
chargé directement par le soleil d'un
côté et par l'énergie du soleil stockée
dans les batteries de seconde vie pour
assurer la recherche du véhicule
ils sont cinq collaborateurs du
technocentre de guyancourt a piloté le
développement de ce projet une
infrastructure d'apprentissage de
recherche destiné à terme à la
commercialisation uniquement dans les
entreprises une étape dans la poursuite
du développement du véhicule électrique
la stratégie globale de renault c'est
d'amener cette technologie électrique au
plus grand nombre et donc au coût le
plus abordable pour voir la massifier et
contribue au réseau de la résolution des
problèmes de la planète
aujourd'hui finalement avec les
autonomie de 300 km que vous avez sur la
zoé derrière moi et puis 390 sur la
nouvelle version de zoé 3 qu'on va
commercialiser à la rentrée on a
vraiment je dirais résolus complètement
ce problème là pour tous les usages du
quotidien la renault zoé le véhicule le
plus commercialisé en europe avec
environ quarante mille unités vendues en
2018 dont dix-huit mille en france
un nouveau conseil d'administration pour
l'établissement public
interdépartemental yvin hauts-de-seine
il se tenait ce mercredi à versailles et
les élus des deux départements se sont
réunis pour faire un bilan des
coopérations mené en 2018 pour rappel le
rapprochement entre les services de ces
collectivités à débuter en 2016 avec
notamment la mise en commun des
compétences de l'adoption de
l'archéologie et de la voirie à
l'horizon la fusion voulue par les deux
territoires les propos sont recueillis
par nicolas d'ombré
l'acte iii assez simplement que l'état
prenne enfin le décret qui consacre la
volonté convergente des deux
départements
de tous côtés j'ai des retours positifs
c'est à dire le
l'administration est au travail pour le
faire on travaille ensemble de façon
très organisée sur maintenant les
collèges tout ce qui est une compétence
propre des départements et les
programmations et et les travaux donc
des choses qui vraiment touchent au
quotidien je parle aussi de l'insertion
on parlait de job 78,92 toutes les
plateformes d'insertion activity
maintenant qui est evelyne et
hauts-de-seine est l'une des compétences
communes entre les deux collectivités
c'est celle de la voirie cet été les
yvelines vont rénover le réseau total 60
chantiers
elles sont programmées sur les 1600 km
d'axa départementaux et les détails avec
ce sujet de michael et demi d'euros et
de patrick jacques de dixmude les
travaux estivaux ont déjà commencé à ou
dans le département aide à la
construction d'une bretelle de sortie de
la rn 12 et la rd 912 via un giratoire
l'été une période propice pour réaliser
ce type d'opération d'envergure
on va estimer qu' on est sur une période
longue
on peut ouvrir un chantier sur plusieurs
semaines
on peut estimer aussi que la météo sera
au rendez vous c'est à dire pas trop de
pluie et des conditions agréables pour
pouvoir travailler dans tous les cas les
matériaux dont on a besoin
je pense aux couches de roulement jeu
mais pas gêné parce qu'il fait pas froid
sera pas gelée
on peut le faire dernier sujet la
circulation est moindre le volume
diminue
au total 60 travaux vont être engagés
cet été sur le département parmi les
plus importants la rénovation de la
chaussée de la rd 988 à rochefort en
yvelines
l'entretien du pont de franchissement de
loi situé entre andrésy et conflans
sainte honorine et les travaux
d'aménagement giratoire du carrefour de
la rd 154 entre orgeval et vilaine sur
scène
le reste du réseau routier sera
également entretenus sur des secteurs
identifiés
il a encore en fonction des aléas
climatiques mais surtout de la densité
de circulation vous avez beaucoup de
camions qui passent sur une chaussée
elle est évidemment plus détériorés que
si vous avez un une route départementale
avec un ou deux milliers de voitures
jour alors que quand je parle de deux ou
trois mille voitures heures c'est pas la
même chose
au total le département des yvelines va
engager 30 millions d'euros de travaux
sur la période estivale sur ses 1600 km
de routes
cette agence départementale est au
service de l'urbanisme encore du
patrimoine des yvelines ingénierie a
fêté ses 50 mardi soir au domaine de
madame elisabeth à versailles retour sur
la soirée avec aurélien dans quelques
mois le centre du village d alu et le
roi va retrouver une seconde jeunesse
montant de ce projet plus d'un million
et demi d'euros
un chantier rendu possible grâce à
ingénierie cet organisme a été créé il
ya tout juste cinq ans par le
département des yvelines
sa mission accompagner les communes
rurales dans leurs projets de
réhabilitation ou de construction
je crois que le pari est réussi c'est
surtout les chiffres qui nous permettent
de dire que le pari réussi puisque plus
de 90% des communes rurales ont adhéré
170 communes rurales ont adhéré les
trois établissements publics de
coopération inter départements
qui ont des communes rurales ont adhéré
également depuis sa création l'agencé a
répondu à plus de 700 demandes toutes
les prestations sont gratuites
le département c'est un acteur de la
cohésion sociale tout le monde le sait
mais si aussi un acteur de la cohésion
territoriale est aux côtés des maires
pour un projet d'école pour un projet de
rénovation de salle des fêtes pour créer
une piste cyclable
je pense que c'est la décentralisation
concrètes
l'équipe d'ingénierie était constituée
au départ de trois personnes
elle en compte 18 aujourd'hui et est
appelée à évoluer dans les prochaines
années
l'assainissement la vidéoprotection le
conseil juridique le conseil financier y
aurait plein d'autres choses à faire on
va essayer de grandir de consolider déjà
des communes qui sera der ende et puis
d'essayer de rajouter très probablement
dans les années à venir d'autres
compétences pour être au plus près des
élus ruraux l'agencé financé à 95 % par
le département les 5% restants
proviennent des cotisations des communes
adhérentes
entre 70 centimes et 1 euro par habitant
j - 1 ce vendredi la france affronte les
états unis pour les quarts de finale de
la coupe du monde de football féminin 7
en france en ce moment l équipe
américaine va s'entraîner ce soir dans
les yvelines à croissy-sur-seine plus
exactement où l'on retrouve mélanie poké
l'entraînement va débuter mélanie dans
quelques instants
oui tout à fait grégory à l'équipe des
etats-unis est arrivé il ya quelques
minutes pour un entraînement à huis clos
alors c'est la cinquième équipe de la
compétition a foulé le terrain de
croissy sur seine vous l'avez dit elle
affronte les bleus ce vendredi et les
deux équipes vont devoir se rassurer à
grégory les huitièmes de finale ont été
tendues les français se sont fait peur
face au brésil dans une rencontre
crispée match difficile aussi pour les
états unis est affronté l l'espagne
alors mardi en conférence de presse
philippe joly l'adjoint de corinne
diacre la sélectionneuse française
confiance ce rendez vous était attendue
depuis des mois les bleus n'ont
rencontré qu'une seule fois les états
unis dans une compétition de coupe du
monde c'était celle de 2011
et cette fois les états unis s'étaient
imposés 3 buts à 1 mais les françaises
pourraient faire pencher la balance de
leur côté puisque le 19 janvier dernier
les deux équipes se rencontrer en match
amical
et cette fois le score était à la faveur
des bleus alors pour la compétition 2019
le verdict du quart sur la cour donnera
ce soir le coup d'envoi est prévu à 21
heures au parc des princes merci mélanie
avec vous aux moyens techniques patrick
jacques de dixmude avec mon plateau
frédéric du cru bon soir alors vous êtes
le président d'un club de foot c'est
l'entente sportive et ans un nom une
association qui regroupe donc les
communes de l'étang la ville et de saint
nom la bretèche vous organisé dimanche
une fête du foot on en parle dans un
instant déjà une petite réaction à ce
duplex les françaises ont-elles une
chance demain face aux américaines qui
sont on va dire les favoris de ce
mondial dur de jouer à la maison
la dernière rencontre a été à notre
faveur mais gagné 3 enfin elles ont
gagné 3-1 et matthieu chalmé chez nous
et puis ce serait tellement beau de
renouveler l'expérience dès de l'équipe
masculine ya quelques années encore on
ne peut que les supporter et puis on va
passer les cinq matches qui est prévue
demain soir à 21h au parc des princes
alors c'est une compétition qui
intéresse les français on l'a vu 12
millions de téléspectateurs à lors du
dernier match face au brésil est ce que
l intéresse aussi les membres de votre
club
oui bien sûr bien sûr on a un certain
nombre de femmes qui sont déjà dire des
gens dans le club
et puis surtout on va remonter dès le
mois de septembre une équipe dédiée aux
jeunes filles qui ont entre 8 et 10 ans
c'est une nouveauté dans notre club pour
l'instant les équipes sont mixtes figue
à fond c'est pas toujours facile pour
les jeunes filles c'est aja de jouer
avec des garçons de leur âge parfois
salée fresnes
elles n'osent pas venir tandis que quand
on leur dit qu'elles joueront entre
elles avec un encadrement qui sera on
l'espère à grande majorité
6001 elles ont davantage dans vie et son
et sont prêtes à s'engager
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a décidé de
monter une équipe de jeunes filles des
prochaines en collaboration avec
d'autres clubs voisins et amis de marly
le roi parce qu'on se dit qu'en en
s'associant on a plus de chances que ça
marche fort pour regrouper les forces et
puis on espère profiter de la dynamique
de l'équipe de france pour embarquer un
certain nombre de jeunes filles et après
progresser dans les catégories soit une
pièce des goristes pour les catégories
pardon pour les joueuses nées entre 2010
et 2012 c'est ça exactement qui ont
entre 8 et 10 ans l'année prochaine
et puis après si ça si ça marche on
entra dans les catégories puis à leurs
idéaux et à partir de cette catégorie
pour avoir ensuite des catégories à plus
grande tout à fait parce que notre club
est essentiellement un club de jeunes on
a 350 licenciés essentiellement des
jeunes entre 5 et 20 21 ans donc voici
la base c'est un peu là diène notre club
de deux former des jeunes et non pas
d'avoir un esprit compétition pourrait
aller d avec des équipes nous ferait
partie donc de la trentaine de clubs des
yvelines sur 153 avoir une section
féminine vous lisez aussi l'idée c'est
profiter de cet effet coupe du monde est
ce que vous l'avez ressenti il ya un an
avec la victoire des bleus en coupe du
monde chez les hommes pour le coup est
ce que vous espérez profité d'un effet
coupe du monde féminine bien sûr comme
chaque fois que l'équipe de france
l'équipe in se manifeste et gagne les
compétitions on voit un afflux de jeunes
c'était le cas l'année dernière c'était
cas en 2006 3 chaque fois que que
l'équipe de france brille on voit un
afflux de jeunes
donc on espère bien sûr profité de la
même dynamique avec le football films
l'un qui comme le disait draine un grand
nombre de prêts de téléspectateurs et
actuellement sur l'île et il reste
encore des places pour intégrer cette
nouvelle section
bien sûr on n'a pas de limites en donc
toutes les toutes les jeunes filles sont
les bienvenus et on pourra avoir plus de
renseignements sur cette section sur
votre site internet est aussi à la fête
du foot
le site internet qui s'affiche aussi
elle a fait du foot qui se déroule donc
dimanche au stade val de source c'est à
l'étang la ville de 10h à 18h là on est
clairement dans l'objectif de faire
connaître le club de fer connaissent
deux clubs de passer un bon moment en
fin de saison pour avec tous les avirons
ou te remercie les bénévoles remercier
les bénévoles
jouer avec les enfants faire des
rencontres entre parents et enfants
bon l'objectif est de passer un bon
moment pour bien terminer la saison
bien commencer la prochaine plus globaux
voilà l'idée de garder la dynamique et
puis de éventuellement de faire
connaître le club depuis notre équipe
féminine concret à la entre 330
licenciés je crois dans votre club
quel est l'esprit l'esprit l'esprit
c'est vraiment cliqué un club de l'ain
coop de jeunes l'idée c'est de former
les jeunes au football
il est aussi de créer une dynamique
autour de tout ça de créer du lien entre
les gens parce que notre club est un
club géré par des bénévoles
notre ambition est de faire venir le
plus de monde possible pour gérer le
club
faire un certain nombre de petites
tailles très simple mais quand on est
plus nombreux c'est plus sympa et ça
marche plus donc on veut faire du
football mais aussi créer du lien au
sein de au sein de nos communes alors
quel est le programme du coup de la
journée dimanche
bon on a différentes activités on a un
baby foot humain une cible géant du bob
dole food and feed et des matchs entre
les enfants et surtout entre parents et
en france qui permet parfois de faire
jouer des gens qui n'ont pas l'habitude
de jouer au football il nous reste une
minute peut-être pour parler un mot sur
les stages aussi que vous organisés
pendant les vacances notamment avec
laurent fournier qui est nouvel
entraîneur de poissy un club yvelinois
exactement tout pendant toutes les
vacances scolaires
chaque jour on a cinq stages qui permet
d'occuper un peu les jeunes faut bien le
reconnaître mais aussi de les faire
progresser en terme de football
l'année dernière on a fait une semaine
de stage avec organisé par leur ont
fourni en collaboration avec avec nos
entraîneurs mais quand ça a bien marché
et on renouvelle l'expérience en au mois
de novembre pour les fêtes
enfin pour les vacances de la toussaint
on retrouve bien sûr un toutes les
informations sur votre site internet et
je rappelle que la fête c'est du foot à
de l'étang à saint nom c'est ce dimanche
au stade de des vals de source et
s'étale et on la vit le rendez vous de
10h à 18h merci beaucoup frédéric
ducreux merci rappelle que vous êtes le
président de ce club l'entente sportive
l'étang est son nom on poursuit notre
série de reportages à présent consacrée
au centenaire du a traité de versailles
ce traité de paix a été signé le 28 juin
1919 dans la galerie des glaces du
château de versailles entre le couloir
mythique est aussi une exposition qui se
déroule
en ce moment sur le document à arras
mélanie poquet marylène iapichino et
nicolas est d'andry reviennent sur le
déroulé de la journée de signatures en
1919 c'est le coeur du château de
versailles la galerie des glaces un lieu
symbolique choisie par le président du
conseil français georges clemenceau pour
la signature du traité de versailles le
28 juin 1919
quand on se rend compte que des le sa
construction elle est achevée en 784 la
galerie des glaces semble cristalliser
dans son décor dans son espace
les relations entre la france et l'
empire le saint empire romain germanique
donc l'allemagne par les représentations
à la voûte qui sont qui marque les
victoires des armées françaises sur les
armes et de l' empire l'organisation de
la cérémonie et fait effectivement pour
mettre en valeur la galerie des glaces
ce lieu symbolique la délégation
allemande arrive la dernière dans la
galerie à 3 heures de l'après midi
toutes les autres délégations que les
autres délégués sont arrivés et c'est à
ce moment que la cérémonie peut
commencer ses clés morceau qui ouvre la
cérémonie en invitant les nids potentiel
allemand a signé les premiers 27 pays
alliés sont représentés par leurs
délégués chacun leur tour ils vont
signer le traité sur ce bureau disposé
au milieu de la galerie des glaces
ce bureau se trouvait dans les
collections de versailles au moment de
la signature
ils avaient été déposés en 1914 shot
versailles il était au palais de
compiègne au 19e siècle dans le salon et
l'impératrice eugénie
il arrive à versailles au début du
conflit et finalement c'est lui qui est
choisi comme beaux meubles bel exemple
d'un
d'un beau bureau pour cette cérémonie de
la signature et le vomi nationale il
place également un fauteuil qui provient
de la salle des fêtes du palais de
l'elysée c'était un porte plume en or
sur lequel est écrit le mot pacs en
émail en émail blanc sur fond de rameau
d'olivier
c'est le monde entier finalement qui
étaient présents à versailles et tous
les continents ont apposé leur signature
sur ce traité et finalement ils vont
réussir à briser les barrières de
protection étaient mises et envahir tout
l'espace pour aller féliciter
congratuler le président wilson david
lloyd george george clémenceau donc dans
une grange aura de félicitations et de
soulagement à l'issue de cette signature
l'original du traité de versailles a été
détruit par les nazis durant la seconde
guerre mondiale le seul reflet de
l'histoire réside dans un numéro spécial
de l'illustration publié le 6 septembre
1919 avec la reproduction de ce document
et dernier épisode de ceux de ce dossier
sur le traité de versailles a retrouvé à
demain dans l'émission 7 8 l'hebdo / tv
78 ces quelques images mignonne pour
refermer ce journal au zoo safari de
thoiry ans et bichonner les animaux en
cette période de canicule distribution
de sorbet aux fruits pour les singes et
les lémuriens et des glaces au sens pour
les fauves ou encore du maquereau givré
donner aux ours au delà du
rafraîchissement c'est un moyen d'amener
de la diversité dans l'alimentation de
ses animaux
c'est la fin du cetud journal replay sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile toutes les idées de sorties
incontournables à faire ce week-end
c'est dans un instant le 7-8 loisirs
avec aux manettes bien sûr marylène
iapichino belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]